you realize as an entrepreneur that you
need help the sooner you'll start seeing
your business scale
the longer you way to try to have all
the work of your business being done by
you the more it's just gonna be stagnant
because there's no possible way that
something can scale without the help of
other people so as a business owner as
an entrepreneur I used to be a winging
entrepreneur I thought I was an
entrepreneur I wanted to call myself an
entrepreneur but I was an independent
contractor that did everything myself I
did all the paperwork processing
everything was me and I was always a
know why the business wasn't growing
until I got an assistant then I realized
the only way things can scale is by
getting help so today I want to talk to
about what things I look for when hiring
a personal assistant for myself either
list them that I'll go through with you
and some of the responsibilities on what
they did for me by the way am I in my
life I went through 26 personal
assistants before the 27th one stayed
with me for nearly 10 years 26 before
the 27th one stayed with me for 10 years
and then many of them stayed with me for
seven eight nine years after the 26 one
so here's some of the things I look for
when hiring an assistant one I'm not
looking for somebody that's extremely
sensitive if somebody is up one day down
one day this boyfriend/girlfriend plumbs
off it's just not gonna work out because
too much sensitivity as an assistant
brings out more stuff on you and a job
of an assistant is to take a lot of the
load off of you for you to focus on the
things that you need to do to is
understanding the word secretary what it
means to be a secretary the word
secretary means somebody that keeps
secrets so if you're going to be an
assistant you need to explain somebody
what it means to be an assistant and the
fact that one of their jobs is to keep
secrets of whatever you talk to them
about behind closed doors about the
business 3 I like to hire assistants
that speak multiple different languages
if you do it's more or less especially
whatever your market may be that you're
dealing with in your business it's
Hispanic if it's to Ghana if it's Asian
if it's middle you know Farsi or mean it
doesn't matter what it is you want to be
able to have somebody that speaks
multiple different language especially
in your market next one is not being
scared of me I don't need
a system that's scared of me and that's
I'm not somebody that I'm looking for or
five challenge them they get too timid
I'm not looking for that I want you to
be able to work with me and not be
afraid of it because you're serious
yourself about wanting to be in business
and learning because I'm gonna teach you
a lot about business another one is
willing to tell me the truth I I if
you're scared you're not gonna tell the
truth if you don't tell me the truth
you're delaying a problem that should be
solved today that three months later is
a bigger problem that's gonna cost me a
lot of money I need you to tell me the
truth when there's issues that come up
another one is not panicking panicking
just creates more panicking for
everybody else I want someone to be calm
collected that handles issues very well
the temperament is very solid there's
not a lot of panicking going are great
on the phones you've gotta be great on
the phones if you're afraid of phone
calls if you're afraid of making phone
calls that person is not somebody won't
have an as an assistant I would
typically when I would hire somebody as
an assistant I would tell them make some
phone calls right in front of me use the
script if they were awkward or
uncomfortable I don't even have time to
teach the phone calls because either
somebody is comfortable making phone
calls or someone needs to be taught how
to make phone calls and he's somebody
that's already comfortable knowing how
to make phone calls pleasant voice I
like a pleasant voice that's over the
phone you enjoy talking to them I'm not
concerned about an accent if somebody
even has a broken accent I'm totally
comfortable with that because I have a
broken accent but I'm looking for a
pleasant voice over the phone the other
one is attractive to the eyes when I say
attractive to the eyes you know I have
friends that - damn it's all about
getting hiring models as assistants
because that's taking it to a whole
different level I'm not looking for
seduction I'm looking for attractive to
the eyes is what I'm looking for another
one is hard-working you got to be able
to be a hard worker my assistants that
I've been with me for years decade 12 13
years some of them they are people that
work very hard regularly they're not
afraid of hard work another one would be
to get along with people they're
generally good with people they don't
have a prompt talking with other people
they get along they're warm they're you
know they know how to build
relationships with folks that's very
very important as a good assistant
they're very protective it's part of the
secretary side they're also very
protective there's no speaking behind
your back all that other stuff that's
not necessary for someone to do I've
hired people like that before
very
quickly a short lifespan the other thing
I would tell you about an assistant if
you're gonna try some out this fire
quickly don't fire a wrong you know
don't wait six months to fire somebody
because you're delaying an issue that
you almost don't want them to be in too
deep that the relationship is stronger
than all of us and you fire them it
hurts so if it's just not gonna work out
you don't feel good about it a week two
weeks cut it right off the bat and let
them know this is a trial for two weeks
before we decide to move forward now the
one there's no hanky-panky with
assistance I tell you this and this may
be a funny thing some people would say
did he just say hanky-panky I actually
did say hanky-panky why I think
sometimes executives and entrepreneurs
you know overpowered their position to
emotional day and next thing you know
they're staying there late and something
happens it is the worst thing you can do
imagine all those years you put together
on having this person be your right-hand
person and then all of a sudden that
gets involved it hurts
everything there's no more leverage
there's emotions attached there's
continuous distractions that could
happen with that you got to cut that
relationship and start all over again
if that has happened before in the past
now what do they do for you
I like reports I like a lot of reports I
like to know birthdays I like to know
events I like to know things that are
specific to me that you give me report
up it's very very detailed on what
things I'm looking for from this person
I give them books to read on a weekly
basis I expect them to read books
specific areas to become better leaders
now you may say well I keep hiring
assistants but I lost a good one and I
lost another good one and I lost another
good one because eventually you need to
pay them well and if you don't they're
gonna go to somebody else who's willing
to pay them well you may not be able to
hire an assistant right now pay them
twenty thirty whatever bucks an hour but
eventually you need to do that to keep
them because there needs to be a victory
for them long-term benefit of working
with you and if you do that right and
you're hardworking person and you get
the right assistant and then from there
you take that same exact philosophy with
hiring other staff around you help
around your support around you around
the same exact mindset next thing you
know you're building an incredible
culture of support team at the home
office of your business that helps you
scale it to new levels that you alone
could never ever do by yourself that's
why you need help if you got any
questions about assistance send me an
email
I'll get back to you my earliest or
comment on the bottom if you haven't
to this channel be sure to do so as well
thanks for watching